car une fois utilisé le bois
mais le bois de chauffe au cul c'est
ok
qui à n'importe quel client autre bord
votre deuxième question il ya une fois
brisé quand même le charbon le charbon
de bois aux cuisines
ok maintenant qu'ils sont qui utilisent
le gaz drapeau qu'ils disent
ok maintenant
aujourd'hui
ma petite histoire un peu
dès l'enfance moi aussi surtout on était
au village
en plus paris je préparais au bois de
chauffe avec les bois
on allait au charbon menée avec le bois
remettait sur les trois pieds en cuisine
et puis
avec tout ce que ça comporte est à fumer
la toxicité et c'est exister ok
en grandissant cette erreur qui dès
cette étape et puis on est passé au
charbon mais le chat va aussi il faut
pas oublier que ça gêne également du
même bois voilà on a passé au charbon
avec les foyers voilà on acheter du
charbon en cuisine elle existe il
existera et ça allait mais en
grandissant on se dit je vous dis on se
dit plutôt les gens utilisent du gaz
faut commencer j'utilise du gaz pourrait
être commode pour vous être dans le game
ou voix et s'était rester focus city gas
pour wasquehal
mais après avoir utilisé le gaz un mois
deux mois ou une année en
on se rencontre plutôt que voilà il ya
ya des prix à payer aux fesses yakuza 2
2 fois la dépister c'est nécessaire dans
tout ça ces coups de mer un stage
d énergie que nous utilisons dans nos
ménages et
parmi ces jeunes âgées les plus utilisés
c'est le le vois de shoot carrément dans
les milieux rural et dans les milieux et
20 par exemple celle
le charbon pour la halle à une modeste
famille au fait voilà et pour les
grandes familles du gaz calme
ce soir
on va voir pourquoi ce que le charbon de
bois est une énergie de première
nécessité en afrique et dans ça quels
sont les défis
et quelles sont les opportunités que
nous avons pour en tirer en salle
voilà
ça c est un peu quatre rapports
l'afrique a eu le taux annuel de pertes
forestières net le plus élevé en 2010
2020 avec 9,3 millions d'hectares
suivie de l'amérique du sud avec 2,6
millions d'hectares on parle de ces
chiffres sur leur ont dit pète faut
rester c'est juste pour 10 et la
déforestation les arbres concours chaque
fois soit c'est peau de chaque poule et
les bois de chauffe soit c'est karim à
pau le transformer à charbon est bon il
ya aussi pour les meubles et tout ça là
aussi ça compte ok en afrique le bois
énergie compte en moyenne pour 70% de
l'énergie totale utilisée d'après les
données 2014 de voilà agences
internationales axées sur elle et la
singularité de l'afrique subsaharienne
risque dans la forte dépendance de la
population urbaine comme je le disais au
bois énergie est là paraît dans la
parole que celui ci occupe dans
l'énergie finale utilisé
en conclut ainsi qu'en afrique le bois
énergie est la principale source
d'énergie
en pratique la plupart des actions et
chant échoué beaucoup d'action et
dominer
ne coupez pas des armes tel ou tel
décret tel quoi exciter l'extrême 1 on a
toujours constaté que ces actions échoué
et que notamment la réduction
significative de la demande de bois
énergie de la voilà selon les données de
l'organisation de la santé l'accès à
d'autres combustibles tels que le gaz ou
le corps et âmes ne s'est pas légèrement
améliorée et compte tenu de la
croissance démographique la population
dépendante des combustibles solides
notamment du bois énergie n'a cessé de
croître au cours des trois dernières
décennies en afrique subsaharienne c'est
pour toujours dit que nous dépendons tu
vois choix du bois énergie chad c du
chan soit du charroi hockey malgré cette
croissance
l'approvisionnement en bois énergie n'a
pas connu la crise annoncée ni pénurie
notoire niveau spectaculaire des prix de
vente et des tailles de bois et du
charbon et du charbon de bois à résumer
tout ça c'est pour dire que nous
continuons toujours par à couper les
arbres
pour fabriquer couper les arbres
directement pour
la cuisine ou directement transformer en
charbon dans les ménages pour cuisiner
mm
les ménages dans lesquels il ya le gaz
tarama les gaz qui utilisent fréquemment
les gaz ya quand même une partie
de cuisson qu'ils font quand même avec
du charbon donc ça veut dire a dit que
le ch a rejoint partout dans nos ménages
maintenant
ça c'est ce que c'est la réalité c'est
ce qu'on constate et c'est ce qu'on voit
qu'elle alors
les conséquences ou les retombées de
cette pratique que nous vivons
actuellement en terme de
retombées conséquences environnementales
ou réchauffement climatique
l'image de la montre un marché à lomé
ici où vous allez voir des sacres la de
sa peau noire c'est un marché du charbon
clairement et les cinq morts là bas que
dans le sac noir au fait il ya deux les
déchets du charbon les déchets de
charbon en fait c'est les résidus c'est
après avoir vendu
le charbon la gommage au savon classique
il ya tout un autre tas de déchets de
brisures de poudre qui dans ses repas
que la femme vous faites ne veut pas il
peut être considéré comme déchet et puis
et puis
à l'inversé c'est une perte elle doit
verser ça ne sert pas actuellement au
jour d'aujourd'hui
voilà un peu le constat et d'autres si
sympa dans les marchés toute banque rue
comme ça vous passez souvent dans les
rues à lomé où vous allez voir un truc
comme ça qui est là un petit creuset où
quelque sorte d'arche maison après avoir
utilisé son sac de charbon il ya ces
déchets s'est brisée qu'il a il vient et
puis elle va peut-être pas la soi disant
je remplis le trou ou bien venger contre
l'érosion voilà
voilà des sacs de ce même mois charbon
et déchets de charbon que les femmes ont
stocké et puis
elles doivent aller vers ces ça dans
l'environnement quelque part et comme ça
gratuitement pour créer et d'autres
dépotoir anarchique de boutoir ovation
politique bon ben moi en tant que
innovateur et voulant tout vous chercher
des solutions appropriées a dit quoi à
une communauté
quand je passe chaque fois
dans les marchés surtout je vois ces
sacs de jute armand stocker
ça me dit quelque chose je m'arrête et
je regarde j'analyse je dis qu'est ce
qu'on pouvait faire avec ça
j'ai compris que c'est un problématique
c'est un problème au fait où
ces sacs de charbon qui sont stockés
constitue un problème économique
économique dans quel sens parce que
c'est une perte sèche c'est de l'argent
qui se faire pour la dame gratuitement
comme ça passait
ne pouvait pas payer pour acheter les
déchets de charge voilà donc un master à
savoir n'avait pas de soucis mais ça
devient une perte d'argent c'est un
problème environnemental
du moment où est la voirie devait passer
prendre ce défi pour aller vers ces
quatre parts dans un environnement et
d'autrefois peut créer un dépotoir
sauvage
un problème en énergétique en ce sens
que le camp le charbon était
en sa forme normale de charbon c'est de
l'énergie on achetait pour cuisiner et
c'est ce que j'appelle sa forme à
l'étape normale à l'état pas voilà on a
fêté ça les tapas pour cuisiner dans son
milieu à les foyers classique maintenant
que le charbon a changé d'étape soit dit
que ça devait s'acquitter l'étape à pau
depuis l'étape b qui elles qui sont
devenus mettra les clichés ça veut dire
que la femme
on n'a plus de solution ça tient au fait
on eu plus peur ne peut plus utiliser ça
n'a plus de solution ça dont je me suis
dit il faut quand même créé
est une solution est à poupet pour
pouvoir utiliser ce combustible cette
énergie un insolite à bombay également
voilà de façon plus efficace et plus
efficiente voilà tu en voilà les
réflexions il ya une équipe qui est
derrière on a réfléchi et ensemble on a
mis et un petit foyer ensemble on a bien
petit foyer en place que nous appelons
le foyer qu aux fouilles échos
le feuilleton aux fêtes
foyer il ya le foyer est qu il ya
économique et écologique donc bref tout
est ce que quelqu'un le foie et la
n'utilise que les déchets de charbon que
nous avons vu précédemment qui sont
stockés et qui doivent aller se faire
verser dans la raquette par terre et des
cieux de chavaux là sont devenus
aujourd'hui
du le combustible le premier qui vaut
qui arrive qui va rentrer dans ce foyer
et prendre feu et cuisine cuisine et
préparer gratuitement comme vous voulez
et plus efficace même que l'achat du
charbon en europe
avec ce chargeur se refroidit ouvert
cette innovation vous allez préparer
tout un mois
vous n'allez pas dépasser plus de 200
francs en termes d'argent mais par
contre
si vous devez devrait utiliser
charron classique dans le foyer
classique au moins si vous achetez 200
francs d'aidé charbon par jour par mois
ça vous faire s'ils me font en moyenne
mais avec ce nouveau modèle vous n'allez
pas vous avez juste besoin d'aller
d'avoir le courage d'aller faire ce
recyclage des déchets de charbon pour
cuisiner et revenus et dépenses et 200
francs comme argent par mois vous allez
me dire comment on peut dépenser sans ça
on dit que votre combustible et gratuit
ce choix est là une possibilité
d'activer le feu par lui-même vous
n'avez plus besoin aujourd'hui de
d'activer ce foyer avec l'éventail comme
nos voiliers classiques non ça vous fait
gagner trois fois plus rapidement le
temps si vous cuisinez dans les foyers
classique en achetant du charbon ou
dépenser 45 minutes ou une préparation
par exemple avec ceux ci en 15 minutes
vous réduisez le temps de comptes depuis
son ca vous réduit le temps de cuisson
au 15 mai ne saviez vous gagner un temps
fou dernière énergie vous n'êtes plus
plus jamais pour activer le feu vous
déplacez 200 francs par mois les deux
enfants là reviennent à quoi au fait les
deux enfants là reviennent à la petite
énergie que ce 22 foyers
il a hélas muni d'un ventilateur c'est
ce ventilateur là qui prend le relais de
l'éventail aujourd'hui voilà qui prend
le relais de l'éventrer ce petit
ventilateur a besoin d'une petite
énergie pour le faire tourner et c'est
cette petite énergie de l'identité qui
vous revient à 200 francs par mois sur
votre électricité voilà on est allé plus
loin au fait pour agrandir la gamme ça
c'est le modèle l'autre c'est le modèle
ménage à la maison papa maman enfant ici
c'est le modèle professionnel qui est
derrière même alimenté directement par
un panneau solaire ça du coup vous les
citer les résidus gratuitement vous
alimenter le foyer avec un panneau
solaire et vous finalement
vous cuisinez gratuitement vous ne payez
rien à personne et vous préparer trois
fois rue peel au plus rapidement
ok ça c'est
la première action
que nous menons que nous avons menées
pour
notre participation aux questions de
l'environnement de l'autre côté
quand nous prenons ce tas de déchets de
charbon il ya
en effet distingué en dessous produit le
premier sous produits c'est le lait
braisés directement tout charles fant a
mis ça en fait le premier sous produits
des brisures qui sont à la main qu'ils
sont tous charges qui vont directement
dans le foyer le deuxième sous produit
de la poudre
la poudre noire de charbon qui la farine
pour la poudre de charbon nous avons
passé autrement que pouvoir vous faire
de cette poudre pour le valoriser en
fait tout ceci c'est pour valoriser les
déchets du chan ok que pouvons-nous
faire avec ça pour valoriser également
cette poudre de charbon nous avons
trouvé des techniques ou de transformer
un briquettes de charbon en le
maintenant dans les machines en les
contactant ça sort des briquettes de
charbon qui peut être utilisé soit dans
nos fois ils sont dans notre foyer soit
dans tous les foyers place et voilà nous
sommes encore aller plus loin puisque
nous avons déjà maîtriser la technique
de fabrication du charbon écologique ça
c'est le un exemple du du foie et de du
charbon fiabilité du chiffre des
briquettes de charbon dans notre foi et
et vala l'intensité le fait trop fort
voilà et
voilà nous sommes plutôt un pari pour
puisque nous avons déjà maîtriser la
technologie donc pour donner partager
cette technologie de fabrication de
charbon écologique alors avec la
communauté dont nous avons déjà eu le
dessus cinquantaine ça c'est un de
vagues où on a formé des étudiants un
peu partout dans comment fabriquer les
déchets de charles et
le charbon écologique à partir des
débris de végétaux à partie des
d'époque de
co2
d'époque du mois de pales des
d'épis de maïs
elle peut en fait tout ce qu'on peut
faire prendre pour fabriquer des charges
est pour lui sans couper la vie c'est ça
l'objectif au fait ce en poupe et lab et
puis nous partageons cette expérience
avec les étudiants les apprenants afin
que cette même action puisse être
répliqué un peu partout dès que la
personne qui chez nous à lomé si la
cuire tuna tara je ne sais pas hyper les
répliques et qu'elle peut qu'il a
d'après peut aller répliquer quelqu'un
qui
c'est pas mango accès sera existera qui
peut aller répliquer donc voilà un peu
[Musique]
nos actions les actions concrètes sur le
terrain que nous faisons déjà afin de
pouvoir
atténuer et vale a réduit la déduire
d'ailleurs la déforestation voilà je
veux aller se préciser au fait quelques
quelques points
les actions là sont d'abord la mise en
place du foyer c'est pour réduire les
dépenses énergétiques liées à l'achat du
charbon c'est pour augmenter
diminuer le temps de cuisson c'est pour
gagner en temps et puis c'est pour
économiser aussi de l'argent c'est pour
également protéger l'environnement c'est
pour réduire la déforestation
comment s'appelle réduire la
déforestation
on considère que
le voit qui a été coupée au préalable
transformer un charbon
on a pas on n'utilisait pas au fait ce
charbon à 100% on l'utilisait peut être
à 110% plairait les 30 pouces à celle
restée les défis qui n'en sert pas donc
aujourd'hui nous on arrive à transformer
ses tracks pour cela en de matière la
plus pure est la première marque thiès
et les débris qui font directement dans
le foyer et la paix 2e mathieu c'est la
cour qui est là encore transformer en
charbon qui qui paie encore été utilisés
donc aujourd'hui si une part une partie
des commandes et des ménages arrivent à
utiliser les trous sont considérés comme
déchets humains qui paie ses fils est
déjà dans les forêts ça voudrait dire on
aura plus d'impact de l'autre côté d'un
d'antan dans la forêt donc ça va quand
même réduit le le taux d'étudiants
déforestation donc voilà un peu quelques
actions concrètes que disons nous
faisons déjà pour
protéger l'environnement réduire la
déforestation et voilà il ya tout
d'autres perspectives qui sont en cours
pour dans le même sens donc
je